[Norvig] And the answer is that it would, in fact, get some of the cases right.
In fact, it would get many cases right.
It would get all the test cases that we've seen so far correct
because in each one of those we can distinguish between 2 hands
just by a single number.
We can distinguish that a full house is better than a straight
just because looking at the numbers that get returned.
For a full house we would return a 6, and for a straight we would return a 4,
and we know 6 is greater than 4,
and so max would do its job and would give us the right answer.
But it wouldn't give us the right answer in all cases.
So for example, what happens if somebody had a pair of 10s and 3 other cards
and another player had a pair of 9s and 3 other cards?
With what we had written so far, pair turns out to be ranking number 1,
and so the hand rank for this would be equal to 1
and the hand rank for this would be equal to 1,
and those would be the same and it wouldn't be able to choose between them.
But we know that we want the pair of 10s to outrank the pair of 9s,
so we've got to come up with some way to make that comparison
so that we're able to distinguish between 2 rankings that are the same
in terms of what they're called.
They're both called pairs, but they differ in what they are:
a pair of 10s versus a pair of 9s.